bienvenue à paroles autochtone ici c'est
melissa maulin dupuis cette semaine je
réponds avec question de stéphanie qui
étaient les jetables et qui me demandent
maintenant qu'on parle beaucoup de
réconciliation comment peut-on organiser
celle ci et surtout comment on peut le
faire en respectant et enfin gardant la
reconnaissance de nos droits
stéphanie une question qui est
extrêmement importante une question qui
va être très dur à répondre à une seule
une solution parce que c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle on s'est mobilisé
pendant la période d'abonnement et
quelques années les droits ancestraux la
reconnaissance de ces droits là dépend
vraiment d'une chose c'est à dire de
connaître les droits vraiment de
s'intéresser à la loi sur les indiens
s'intéresser à la constitution
canadienne s'intéresser aussi aux droits
qui se présente devant les cour suprême
parce que c'est pas des droits qui sont
accordés par le gouvernement canadien
mais ces deux lois qui sont reconnus par
ces droits là il existe depuis avant
l'arrivée des européens avant le premier
contact c'est pour ça qu'on dit droits
ancestraux
c'est que ils ont continué d'exister
depuis le premier contact jusqu'à
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir les organiser
il faut les connaître il faut les
pratiques et aussi d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'ils existent encore aujourd'hui
c'est qu'ils sont pratiqués ils sont
encore très vivant donc faut transmettre
ces informations là à nos enfants pour
leur montrer aussi comment justement les
lois les convois en cours aussi c'est
fait pour éteindre ces droits-là donc
comment combattre ces outils sont
utilisés pour détruire les droits
ancestraux et dans l'angle
réconciliation il faut aussi éduquer la
population non autochtone sur ces droits
là parce que les ignorent tout des
droits ancestraux ne comprennent pas
pourquoi des droits de chasse de pêche
de kate qui sont très différents de ceux
des canadiens et pour qu'ils aient une
réconciliation véritable il faut qu'ils
aient une reconnaissance et l'europe
une restitution des territoires et de
de notre pratique ancestrale pour
pouvoir justement qu'est une véritable
réconciliation alors stéphanie je te
souhaite bonne chance parce que c'est un
travail et non et ça demande beaucoup
d'éducation non seulement au sein de nos
communautés mais ça demande d'éducation
aussi au sein des communautés
environnantes
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo et
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions
je souhaite une très belle semaine à
paroles autochtone